most of this generation quits the second
they get talked to you did this wrong
you did this wrong it's so easy to you
know I mean to to be great nowadays most
people are weak this this is a softened
generation so if you have any mental
toughness any any ability if you have
any fraction of self-discipline the
ability to not want to do it but still
do it it wasn't until I changed that
mentality that I became somebody if you
can get through to doing things that you
hate to do on the other side is
greatness that's what people understand
by me running I am callous in my mind
I'm not training for a race I'm training
for life I'm training for the time when
I get that 2 o'clock in the morning call
that my mom is dead or something happens
tragic in life I don't fall apart